Lewis Terman a psychologist from Stanford University created an American
version of an IQ Test called the Stanford-Binet test. The Stanford-Binet test
was the first to have national norms not just local ones, like the last ones we
saw that was localized for Paris. The Stanford-Binet tests use the same IQ
ratio as we talked about before. Mental age over chronological age times the
average, which is 100. The test focused on three main domains, Verbal,
language, Quantitative, math, and Spatial. One problem with the test, however,
was that the questions they used were only for children and teenagers. So adult
intelligence couldn't be measured. David Weschler solved this problem by
creating a test of intelligence for adults, called the Weschler Adult
Intelligence Scale. This looked at the same domains as the Stanford-Binet test.
This test asked questions that were more adult appropriate. For example, why
the individuals buy automobile insurance, or in what ways are boats and trains
the same. Modern versions also test working memory, with problems such as the
examiner saying three numbers for example three, nine and seven. And then the
person is asked to repeat them back, or eight numbers, eight, five, nine,
seven, four, three, seven, two. And again, the person has to repeat these. The
more numbers a person can recall the greater their working memory is.